i have a ton of questions for you guys
but one of the things is i've been
waiting for something national treasure
since the second movie and i'm sort of
curious for you guys on the end um how
talk a little bit about how it ended up
being a series at disney plus and um you
know was it hard to pull off like in
terms of getting the studio on board
yeah i mean
uh no
uh we got a call from the studio asking
um
i think they asked jerry to do the
series and uh
luckily jerry uh
thought about us
um so it's always been like for us to
blow they've they've wanted it to be
good and marianne and i uh hopefully
they like this and hopefully they like
that and and we've gotten it to this
this level we've always
we've always wanted to make the the
third movie but until then we had always
thought about doing tv so we always
thought it would we could do a spin-off
in a television universe and so we're
very lucky that disney plus had us do it
how many episodes is the series
10.
[Laughter]
right i'm so i'm curious for the cast
obviously uh how what are you actually
most excited for fans to see in the
series and um i guess let me start with
that
um well i would say that uh the treasure
that we follow and uncovering all of the
mysteries um that we have on the show
each episode kind of leads into the next
um so you know i think parts of the the
treasure were mentioned in the second
film and i don't know if i could say
that but
the pan american treasure because it was
introduced then so it's a continuation
of the original uh movies only 20 years
later and so we go off of that adventure
yeah
i'm excited for people to see how much
we've really expanded the world because
if you liked the first two movies we're
essentially giving you 10 mini movies so
this still has the same spirit of that
amazing action that you get from the
movies we deliver a huge set piece in
every single episode but because we have
10 hours we can give you the action but
also really get into the character study
of all these people so you really fall
in love with them even more on the
journey and at the end of the day i
think people are just gonna have fun
watching it it's an hour of escapist
television kick back with your family
it's just gonna be a good time for
everyone i was uh i was gonna say i
think it also shines a light on um
uh the parallel to the excitement of
treasure hunting it also shows the
dangers of treasure hunting in a very
deep way uh my character liam sadusky is
the grandson of peter sadowsky who was
the head fbi agent on the original two
movies following the case and you see
through liam the damage that can be done
from trejonte i feel like the first two
movies showed the dangers but um he is a
byproduct of the aftermath of that
lifestyle and i think he'll show
audiences a different side to it as well
we just put a lot of blood sweat and
tears into this one literally
and you know the chemistry that we all
have on screen is like in real life so
to follow a young group of people and to
follow the perspective of jess who's uh
with dhaka and as an immigrant and just
dreams to be
a citizen and in the fbi it's just a
really great new fresh take on the
series in the world so it's ten episodes
uh i'm curious for each of you do you
have a favorite episode of the ten uh
which is obviously not a spoiler it's
just telling people what episode you
can't wait it's not interesting like
maybe five um we do something really
interesting in five that there's like a
really cool location um and everybody
looks beautiful
so you know i think i think five might
be my my favorite spoiling too much i
think uh
one of my favorites is probably episode
three because it's the first time that
you wait actually i don't know if i can
say that but
i'm not trying to get you in trouble
but like it was it was it was wonderful
we all got to work as an ensemble and it
was it was really
really awesome yeah it was great
yeah i would say
for me and
seven
because it's the time that we get to say
jess gets to say i'm going to do it i'm
going to plank
what am i going to do what am i going to
do
by the way
once the show runner actually says
something like that you can now talk
about it i know all right i have liberty
thank you very much
um yeah i would say my favorite going
going off of that it's like seven and
eight i think those are very pivotal
points in my character's decision making
and like
and also just trusting herself and that
for me that was
one of my favorite things that i've
learned about my character and how i
applied it to myself so i'm personally a
finale guy
[Laughter]
tin is just insane yeah i mean i i gotta
i mean like if if you stay along for the
journey ten is the biggest payoff ever
uh yeah i'm a finale guy i gotta say i'm
always almost always a penultimate
episode girl because i always feel like
in the penultimate episode you're like
you're setting up that world and also in
nine i got to have three really rad
action sequences and yeah yeah so for me
i was like as i physically prepped a lot
for the role and did like a lot of
training and um so i got to like really
just go like full steam ahead and nine
zero nine i'm team nine yeah
so i'm sure disney plus is hoping this
is gonna be a hit and i'm curious when
you go into pitch the studio how much
are they sort of asking you okay so
here's your plan for season one what is
your do you already have an idea for two
and three if you get to make it or do
they sort of say let's just worry about
one season at a time
yeah it's different now uh
they used to ask you what's season three
but they just we just pitched out the
first season and we uh well you know we
ended the movie with page 47 and had no
idea what that was so uh
so
well we'll see how this works
well let me ask let me also ask this how
important is it that each season maybe
has its own treasure where there's like
a resolution to the storyline so you can
start again is that is that something
that for us it is it's the 10 season
it's a 10 episode arc for one treasure
each season is how we envision it and um
we've already been you know knock on
wood trying to think of what where we
would go for season two but um knock on
wood we'll see you know what happens but
it you know it's constantly swirling
treasure
i'm also curious obviously catherine
zeta-jones is a part of your show uh she
does not do that much tv um she's pretty
selective so what was it like working
with her and getting her on the series
um it was such a cool experience
i grew up watching her and she's always
been a big inspiration and so it was it
was another full circle moment you know
but um i don't know just her energy on
set was just so professional and she's
so kind and i you know even on my hard
days she would welcome me with open arms
so it was just it was just awesome you
know to get to talk to her and learn
about her life and get advice from her
as an actress yeah yeah she's got she's
got an insane presence like you always
want to bring your best when you're with
her you know i mean she's hollywood
royalty for sure like yeah as for
getting her on the show uh well
she was our first choice uh we're huge
fans of hers and uh and she read the
pilot script and she was interested so
we got it on a zoom and uh marianne
pitched her her whole back story i
pitched my heart out yeah
and
yeah her whole family
what how the treasure is personally
connected to her character and she she
liked it enough to say yeah okay i'll do
it and we've been thrilled ever since we
could pinch each other on the set every
day
yeah she's super like pilot hollywood
royalty but the nicest most lovely
person that you could ever meet so i
love learning about like the making of a
show or the making of a movie so um i
don't know if you'll be able to answer
this but let's give it a try is there
anything soon to be fans of this series
would be surprised to learn about the
actual making of the series
i always freak out when we step on set
and the sets are
practical like we're not dealing with
cgi or anything
with dealing with a set that you can
actually use and it's functional
so everything you're seeing is is kind
of real and that's kind of a dream for
an actor to
we don't have to think so much about
pretending it's like we're actually
doing it that's like one of the fun
things that i think the fans are gonna
love about this
one thing that was kind of cool about
our show this has never happened to me
before i don't know if it has for any of
y'all um we shot in baton rouge and our
show is set in baton rouge and that
never happens so you know you're always
like shooting new york for somewhere
else and um so i think if you're
somebody who's from baton rouge it'll be
cool to be like here's landmarks because
i know when i watch a show and it's like
shot in la i'm like there's ventura
boulevard like there's this place so
that's pretty cool that's pretty rare
yeah it was weird like seeing
our apartments in the back of some shops
it's like we were literally
living right down the street and like
walking to work it was very cool it was
very an interesting
situation to be like dropped in this
in in baton rouge and it's like summer
camp and we all got to
be
best friends and like hang out with the
crew cast everybody everyone was a big
family it was it was amazing yeah a very
hot
very hot very hot it got very hot in the
summer
actually in my life um the way that i
have sweated in baton rouge you know
um yeah i was going to say that the heat
and humidity in louisiana is no bs it's
crazy it's crazy and
you know what for the um last two
episodes we film in a very again special
location but like out in
the louisiana
elements elements
[Music]
elements wonderful work thank you lyndon
smith
um you know so very very real i did a
set visit in louisiana not to put myself
in this at all and i apologize but um
where we were walking over this plank to
get to the boat and they said seriously
don't fall in there's alligators yeah
yeah
exactly
there were there are a few days where we
had uh you know alligator wranglers and
snake wranglers just on set just to make
sure everything was good we saw a few of
them just tried to get in the shot
but luckily you know we didn't fall in
the water
that's another thing about the snake i
did a maze runner set visit and the
whole uh
snakes in the grass they had people
going out there to make sure that it's
crazy there was this one time where i i
swore i saw a snake and i kept going no
i can't cross there i think i saw a
snake people like oh i don't know a
snake wrangler was like i'll check he
literally just jumps into the bush and
just starts like stabbing things and
then all of a sudden he picks it up and
everybody starts running they're like oh
hell no
not today
i remember like normally you have like
the neighborhood cat or the neighborhood
dog they're like oh yeah it's a
neighborhood gator yeah it just comes
around sometimes they'll come up if you
feed it no we're like oh word all right
that's cool uh and i don't know if
anybody has um seen this if you're in
baton rouge there's these grasshoppers
that are no joke like literally they're
like six inches long and they're black
and they'll just fall on you and they
would just fall on us during scenes and
there was this one night i apparently i
took a stowaway home with me and i got
in the car to come back to work the next
day and i looked over and the passenger
seat was a dinosaur of a grasshopper and
luckily i wasn't on the freeway but it
was like what is this monstrosity
yeah they were everywhere yeah i know
that oftentimes casts that get along and
it seems like you guys do uh form a text
chain so i'm curious who is the one who
texts too much all the time oh
definitely not me
it's not me either i definitely have a
text chain um actually we we we started
one as soon as everyone was casted it
started with leset and then me and then
like it just grew grew and grew yeah um
but as far as an avid texture i honestly
can't even say what do we think we're
all even we just sent a lot of pictures
to each other yeah darling my favorite
thing is you know sending an invite in
the group and then no one responding and
then sending a photo and then people be
like oh love the pic
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah love you guys thanks friends for
being so supportive
um i definitely have to ask uh obviously
nick cage is you know
known for national treasure and i know
you have heart pitell and justin and
kath but i'm so curious what is the
dream to have nick cameo at some point
on the series
oh yeah the dream is absolutely uh you
know we wanted him to be featured in an
episode this season but his schedule
just didn't work out so that the cameo
we'll still try to get him featured in
an episode if we get a second season
we're all about uh nick cage we we love
him and we want him and
and uh but at the very least a cameo
one of the other things you mentioned
louisiana baton rouge um how much when
did you know early on in the writing
process that louisiana was going to be
the place you guys were filming and were
you sort of writing to that because
obviously louisiana has great tax breaks
georgia has tax breaks we you know
everyone knows if you don't know tax
breaks bring the production to a state
so i'm just curious how did it end up
with louisiana
no we wanted louisiana from a story
standpoint from the beginning we wanted
we had told the story of the colonies
and the northeast and uh the founding
fathers and we really wanted to go south
tell the story of the spanish and the
mississippi river we needed the
mississippi river yeah we needed the
mississippi for the story and um so we
always had intended um on on using baton
rouge as baton rouge or nola as nola we
but baton rouge ended up being a better
choice for us for our story have you
guys released when the show is actually
coming out or it's just like this year
are we a lot we're not allowed to say
soon
we're looking off cameras at people from
the studio and they're all shaking their
head no
like do we even know
can we say it's this year
i would i could
streaming streaming okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna place a wager and you guys
finished filming a few weeks ago
i'm going to say december i'm going to
say december november december is my
guess
depending on how many vfx you have
that's definitely one of the months out
of the year
i'm with you i'm with you
so talk a little bit and i apologize for
asking your showrunners another question
but talk a little bit about where you're
at in the edit and in terms of what
you've learned as you've been cutting uh
and you know what makes you really happy
oh gosh we've uh we we've learned a lot
yeah yeah we've learned a lot about the
process and we have incredible partners
at jb tv and uh disney branded and
um
uh abc's uh signature we're learning so
much in the process we have seen uh
almost all the episodes uh i've seen
them all yeah we have part of 108 we
haven't seen but we've seen all the
episodes and we're always every day we
just we're so thankful for to our
episodic directors and our amazing
amazing dps and also a shout out to our
um production designers because
everything like you're saying looks
incredible um and somehow we got trevor
robin back to do the music who did the
music in the movies so
it's very exciting so yeah to see the
score like on the show again but like
with a little latin next twist um it's
just like it's just it makes us it gives
us chills yeah i'm just about out of
time with you guys but we're at
comic-con and so for each of you guys
what is the thing that you sort of
obsess over or geek out about and is it
here at comic-con
oh 100 i mean uh
wait we got we got a talker finally
oh yeah um definitely i mean
i'm gonna go see all the star wars
things i'm gonna go see all the game of
thrones things whatever
any of that stuff i'm gonna freak out
about i would have literally cosplayed
as either anakin skywalker from the
third movie or
jon snow so if i were to have so maybe
tomorrow i will we'll see
yeah i mean
basically
growing up i was always such a comic
book and video game guy and i still am
um so i just want to see all things nerd
basically i just want to geek out as
much as i possibly can i have really no
direction i kind of just want to go
tomorrow morning and just i don't know
go to my feet hurt that's basically my
plan i want to consume everything i
possibly can down there yeah i mean even
passing the costume and seeing them go
i'm like oh god well we have the time
man yeah i want to see everything
um it's not a comic book but i'm a
massive severance fan like massive and
um i remember saying oh if i'm gonna see
this cast i'm gonna have to stop them
and then we came off from our panel and
went into the green room and it just so
happened to be that severance was on
after us
and so i walked in and i was like
this is incredible ran right up to britt
lauer and i was like your performance um
so i got to have my geeking out moment
over them and i did like watch their
panel on the the screen but yeah
severance was a big like a good good sea
for me yeah yeah
anything marvel like i'm obsessed with
but this is my first comic-con this is
all of our first comic-con and i hear
the art
is incredible so i really want to check
those artists out and see if i can
pick up anything yeah
yeah i second that i love marvel
anything marvel is my go-to um but i'd
also say harry potter
i'm a big potterhead and then also
avatar the last airbender yeah i can
recite the whole beginning of it
actually by memory so i feel pretty
proud about that
so they know i uh just
kind of learned what cosplay was
yesterday
um so i someone asked me what was my
favorite movie growing up and i said
tarzan so if i had to choose a character
it would probably be tarzan i know that
it's not here but you know actually it
wouldn't surprise me if when you're
walking on the convention floor it's one
of the booths has something tarzan
related so there we go then that's set
up just for me
is there anything for you you know i
look we i wish i had dressed up as uh
ripley from the alien i i wish i had we
just we weren't prepared we that would
have been cool
next time i will say for you guys who
have never been to comic-con uh the best
thing is to just be able to walk it's
first of all it's massive the convention
floor but the best thing is just start
on one end and just walk up and down
every aisle and um you'll find some of
it is hollywoodized and some of it is
real indie and it's like a melting pot
of everything i think you guys will love
it and um hopefully next year as you
come back hopefully
and you walk through you'll have to wear
a mask so people will you know because
of the show's popularity
you know
anyway look i'm really looking forward
to seeing your show thank you so much
for coming by
and thank you good luck with the rest of
your speed dating today
thank you thank you so much thank you
pleasure